so for everyone like me who loves the
queen's platinum jubilee there are other
people going well why are we wasting all
this money on this this sort of whiff of
republicanism always sprouts up when we
have this sort of thing going on uh so
we're going to debate this now as the
bunting goes up and the final rehearsals
have taken place uh buckingham palace
has told pageant organizer to avoid
over-egging the queen but i don't
understand why i wanna i want to
overrate the queen's whole point i don't
wanna give these anti-royals any more
material uh as it is but others say come
on cost a living we should be careful
joining me now political commentator
marina perkins and conservative writer
esther cracker welcome to both of you so
uh mourinho tell me why we shouldn't be
lavishing this money and attention on
this fabulous lady to celebrate the
greatest reign in the history of our
country's monarchy because we've
literally got government ministers doing
the rounds telling people they need to
tighten their belts there's not enough
money for this that and the other people
are choosing between heating and eating
and you're telling me it is right and
not at all tone deaf to spend a fortune
local governments by the way who are
completely cash-strapped you think it's
right for them to spend money on these
frequalty i actually do because i think
that this is a chance to celebrate not
only an historic moment for the country
but to remind the world what we do best
pomp pageantry
monarchy these are great things for our
country classism inequality people bored
into insane privilege of wealth why do
we care so much
no i'm sorry but this is bigger than
that this is about the country's morale
and we're going to add to that by saying
actually we can't celebrate the queen
there's so many there's so many
government departments and councils that
spend money ridiculously i can think of
so many ways that our money goes down a
black hole of poor spending right and i
have no problem with this being actually
a good thing and i'm spending money on
it because it's much bigger than that
this queen has given us seventy years of
her life i'm this could be always
raining exactly this could very well be
her last you believe this job out there
who would say no to that would you
incredible you're working at 96 would
you be touring the country and working
at 96. or would you be happy
oh absolutely not i'm sorry no sorry
sorry ask every other person who's doing
a normal job like working in a factory
working in a shop putting in the hours
because they would retire if they could
not wait to remember if they wouldn't
swap positions with the queen she has
had an incredibly privileged life where
will you be
okay at the weekend where are you going
to be
um i am doing nothing to celebrate the
the liquids you believe you won't be in
the pub enjoying the days off again
you might be having an orange juice i'm
going to enjoy my days off i'm not going
to go to the office still but um i'm not
do you think she gets so many days off
at 96. i think she does barely nothing
i'm sorry
well the queen does barely nothing she's
a 96 year old woman who does a huge
number of engagements every year
actually what she does i'll tell you
what she does in times of trouble this
woman has given us a sense of calm she's
given us a sense of morale boosting we
saw it with the amazing documentary
overnight on bbc she's done this her
entire life having inherited a crown at
25 26 years old and she's still going
now and she's just a calming presence in
our country which reminds the world the
very best of what it means to be british
i think esther i i completely agree and
i'm so shocked that you said she does
nothing have you ever heard of the
commonwealth i didn't say this okay what
is the common one what is the common one
well apparently they go around just
defending the commonwealth actually no i
come from a commonwealth country and
that this woman has dedicated her life
to this fantastic institution that has
brought on so so many good values to
different people in different parts of
the world you probably won't even
imagine because you're here saying oh
she does nothing you're sitting in your
comfortable comfortable lifestyle saying
she does absolutely nothing and i bet
you when you're even 80 you wouldn't
what i would say i would say look i'm
saying here's the point i would say when
he got a prime minister who's lying
through his back teeth passing breaking
his own laws when he's ordering the rest
of us to go to lockdown when you
actually have alongside that a woman
who's been on the throne for 70 years
and has never behaved like that who's
always behaved with dignity decorum
respect humility
we're talking about against a backdrop
of boris johnson anyone looks half
decent well that's true
and also she by the way the queen could
do something really nice here she could
like subtly not to the fact we've got a
prime minister running roughshod over
our democracy and our politics but she
doesn't she only steps in when it
benefits her like when she lobbied the
government to change transparency law so
the public couldn't see her wealth i'm
sorry i don't respect that that's
awesome that would that would be
overstepping the mark no i'm sorry
because because the queen is meant to be
neutral the queen but she is she's lobby
three times revealed by the guy because
it wouldn't have been who wouldn't have
been i can't believe we were reading the
guardian for god's sake it wouldn't have
been appropriate but this may be the
problem i think you're reading too many
things in the guardians i know follow
talk talk
well no i'm gonna leave you there it's
very good debate thank you both of you i
like the passion for this debate a lot
of people will agree with both of you so
thank you